Helen and I not knowing each other well
I think made for an unfamiliar T and an
awkwardness that I think in a weird way
the camera loves so I think that a that
that filmed up something very unique
which is that they can capture first and
only moments between people and a lot of
what you see in the first session scene
is happening in real time for the only
time so we were able to I think capture
a lot that that was beneficial to the
story and I think every love scene is
unwieldy and awkward and unintentionally
funny often and then edited into
something along more along the lines of
the perfect fantasy and for us we
weren't interested in that we would
think we embraced the awkward as what we
did you know I've done movies where
there's weeks and weeks of rehearsal
lived in movies where you walk in the
first day and you're shooting and and so
I'm as long as I feel like I've done my
work whether it's with the other actor
or on my own I'm willing to do in
anything I don't I was not smart enough
to think wouldn't it be great if we
hardly knew each other and rehearsed
very little and showed up I just later
when you asked I realized oh that that
you know probably was perfect I feel
like there's a lot of trust from the
start without knowing each other which I
thank you for to begin with but but as
we got to know each other we shot the
subsequent intimate scenes and our
characters were getting to know each
other and gaining familiarity and
comfort too so really well I will say at
the wrap party when first of all he
showed up like this and I was like whoa
whoa no no sexy with the hair and I am
not at all prepared for that but I we
did look at each other and say what did
we just do what happened it was so quick
and there was no conversation and we you
know poured ourselves into the work I
think with all of our hearts and souls
and bodies and then went I just had this
crazy dream where we were naquin what
was that John insisted on
having that limited head movement about
90 degrees at best and that in a way
determined a lot of the camera angles I
mean he only had one screen direction
and a lot of the photography was nailed
down by that fact but I think that you
know when he had his introspective
moments alone we would occasionally go
to a Top Shot and I think also one of my
favorite scenes in the film where the
two of them together you know their last
time having the kind of post-coital
pillow talk about what a relationships
are about I mean I think that's a
beautiful top shot and I'm glad that we
didn't overuse that angle and kept it
for moments like that didn't have to
invent a lot with Marc's autobiography
his poetry his journalism Jessica used
amazing movie and I also liked the idea
of trying to embody Mark O'Brien in the
best way that I could I wanted people
who knew him to recognize as much of
their friend or relative in what I'd
done as possible
the documentary was certainly very
engaging and it was a wonderful
opportunity to see you know and hear
mark and and have a sense of you know
this was a real person that we were
talking about not just you know a
figment of someone's imagination and I
think that you know we we certainly were
really thrilled when Jessica you saw the
film Sundance and loved it and and was
very moved by it and you know not only
her but other people who knew Mark have
seen it since and and they just are all
aghast at how much like Mark John was
able to be and and how much he captured
Mark's personality and and just even the
sound of his voice it's mentioned in in
the script a couple of times that Mark
spine is horribly curved and to that end
I conceived of a device that I would
would lie on in order to curve my spine
there were really many physical
challenges Mark's body was was twisted
by polio in a specific way and also I
needed to learn to type with a mouth
stick and turn pages of a book make
telephone calls of them
stick that kind of thing so there's
several problems to solve from a
physical side I mean I just read it and
it was beautiful
and it's such a rare thing that just
closed the final page and say oh my god
that's a beautiful thing I want to be in
that and that's so precious to me that
is like you know the most precious thing
that happens in my creative work and
after the first few days of shooting our
cameraman was running around like mad
doing the job of many people and I was
very worried about him
and I said Jeff you're going too fast so
don't worry I said are you at least
enjoying yourself
and he said I'm having a fantastic time
and at that point I that was another
corner turned in that if he was having a
good time then we were making a good
film